before this video loaded you probably
watched an ad and/or one will appear
right about now how did this exact ad
get on this video and what you really
want to know how much money do these
things make okay there are three players
in this game
creators who create videos advertisers
who make the ads and YouTube who plays
matchmaker matchmaker making the match
now unlike old dying media where a dude
in a room could place ads on predictable
known content at a leisurely schedule
YouTube doesn't work like that
can't work like that because on YouTube
there is no schedule at any moment a
wild viral video can appear on a normal
day 65 years worth of videos are
uploaded to YouTube and people watch a
billion hours of video it's an endless
waterfall of random content that just
keeps growing hiring enough humans to
categorize all those videos and match
ads to them would be impossible this is
a job for boss the moment each new video
is uploaded YouTube's BOTS get to work
looking at the title the keywords the
captions the comments the controversy
all to make their best guess as to what
category it belongs in meanwhile
advertisers tell their own BOTS what
category of videos they want their ads
to run against and what kinds to avoid
and here is where YouTube earns their
money between when you click on a video
and when it plays a YouTube bot holds an
auction announcing the categories its
guest the video is in opening the floor
to all interested advertisers or BOTS to
place their bids the winning advertiser
bot is the one with the ad that will
most likely make YouTube and the Creator
the most money at that instance but
that's not necessarily the highest
bidder different ads pay in different
ways for example skippable video ads the
advertiser doesn't pay if the viewer
skips as soon as they can the advertiser
only pays if their ad is clicked or
watched a super high bid means nothing
if the ad is super boring no click
equals no dollars for YouTube or the
Creator so there's a bias against boring
the auctioneer BOTS will prefer a lower
bid for an ad with a higher click rate
than a higher bid for an ad with a lower
click rate but boring is in the eye of
the beholder so in addition to YouTube's
BOTS trying to guess what the video is
about there are BOTS that try to guess
what the viewer is about looking at
their watch history and
device and activity to try and guess
their age chromosomes income location
and interests this information too is
part of the auction and the advertisers
can instruct their BOTS to only bid to
specific demographics and specific
locations and specific categories and
only up to specific amounts so whatever
ad you saw before this video didn't plan
to be there it was the result of bought
guesses about the video and bought
guesses about you and bought bids for
your attention and that exact
millisecond watch videos from this
channel' on the device of someone
demographically different and you'll see
different kinds of ads you should try it
with this video on at least two or three
or four look watches video on a lot of
different devices anyway if you want to
know how much advertisers pay YouTube
and creators there isn't one answer it's
all and insta oxygen and varies wildly
by video category the viewers the time
of year advertising budget how many
auctions are happening at that exact
moment and how full they are it's
millions of matches a minute of supply
and demand channels with prized
demographics may earn five times as much
per view as other channels but you and I
both know there's still some kind of
average number something to use as a
ballpark and that's what you want to
know on average this number how many
Benjamins
okay a reasonable estimate is one view
is worth one quarter of one penny split
between YouTube and the Creator which is
the first time a penny has proved too
great a measure of value so a better way
to think about it is 1,000 views
generates about 250 of advertising
dollars YouTube then splits that money
between the creator and themselves 5545
about 144 the creator and 110 for
youtube or if you want to think big
about it every million views is 1,400
dollars for the creator and 1,100 for
youtube again on average particular
channels might be splitting 50 cents per
thousand or 450 per thousand it all
depends on the auction so that's how it
works
the Niagra of content sorted and sold by
box to bots for humans to watch
[Music]
you